billionaire friend gave me this piece of  investing advice that i've taken with me  for life telling him about some of the  scripture stuff and some of these other  things that are going on i was like dude  i feel like i'm going to miss out and he  said mistakes level rush decision and  whenever you feel like you're missing  out you're probably missing out on the  fall that's going to come i've taken  that as two different lessons for me  number one is that if i'm in a rush i  slow down before i put money into  something and number two is that feeling  of fomo of like oh my god i'm about to  miss out is what happens right before  the crash that is one of the alarms i  set off in my brain to say you know what  take an extra five seconds and really  think about this before you go all